my name is Lee Smolin and I'm a
theoretical physicist I work at Kramer
Institute for Theoretical Physics in
Ontario Canada and I work on the most
fundamental problems about nature what
is time
what is space what is the universe as a
whole where did the universe come from
what started at what was before the Big
Bang
in physics we study systems we study the
air in this room we study the elementary
particles created by a collision at the
Large Hadron Collider we study the solar
system or the galaxy is a system of
stars and these are all parts of the
universe as a whole and it's very
important that we treat them as parts of
a larger universe so that for example
where they are or how much energy they
have is to find relative to the rest of
the universe that's outside the system
so the very way we describe parts of the
universe as related to the rest of the
universe is characteristic of the method
by which we describe nature in physics
and when we raise our ambition and we
come to the question of the universe as
a whole or a question that is about the
whole story of the whole universe like
the big burner have you ever started or
what was before the Big Bang we're
dealing for the first time with the
question of how to describe and make a
theory of the universe as a whole and
this is a very different kind of theory
a very different kind of questions and
the questions we used to dealing with
and therefore it's important to stop and
meditate for a while on what it means to
make a theory of the universe or any
system as a whole
when we describe a star we do reference
it wouldn't describe it with respect to
things outside of it we describe its
position relative to the position of an
observer who's outside of the star when
we describe its motion we're describing
its motion relative to something outside
of it and so on
and that works that's the legitimate way
to do science except for when we come to
the case of the universe as a whole and
then we have to describe a system that
contains everything there is nothing
outside the universe and there therefore
is nothing to describe the universe with
reference to and this means we need a
very different kind of structure a range
of a kind of method a different kind of
theory when we come to study the
universe as a whole
because there's a tradition of thinking
deeply seriously and critically that
goes back centuries which is what you
learn when you study philosophy now if
you're not interested in a fundamental
question like the nature of time or what
is matter or the nature of the universe
as a whole but you just want to apply
known laws to known phenomena to
understand the better to understand the
behavior of a solid or the gas or a star
or something isolated like that you can
proceed without much knowledge of
philosophy you can proceed pragmatically
we like to say but if you want to ask
the really deep questions there are
these traditions of human beings
grappling with the same questions they
go back hundreds of years and not only
is it good to know them because it gives
you a storehouse of ideas it allows you
to understand your own thinking because
what you discover is that unless you're
extraordinarily special and unusual your
thinking is shaped by the philosophical
legacy that underlies our civilization